I've waited 30 years for this
I still remember my last orders while
2015 Star Wars Battlefront brought
multiplayer battles based on the
original trilogy battlefront 2 broadens
the scope to include all eras of Star
Wars Canon and unlike the previous game
this one features a brand new
single-player campaign here's everything
we know about battlefront 2 so far and
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss any more details
we weren't expecting special forces
that's the point sergeant Bala front 2
single-player stars I Denver CO an
imperial commander who's seeking to
avenge the Emperor following the
destruction of the Death Star that means
the game picks up after the end of
Return of the Jedi and it covers the
30-year span between that movie and the
force awakens the Empire aren't the
antagonists and battlefront 2 instead
we're getting a different perspective
than we normally do there will also be a
brand new planet items homeworld of our
dose and we get to see the battle of
jakku ITINs unit is an elite group
called inferno squadron droids and
gadgets are going to be a big part of
combat but there will also be
opportunities to fight like a regular
soldier most of the story will be from
the Empire's perspective but there will
also be missions where you play as
established characters including Luke
Skywalker and kylo Ren if you're
wondering yes this story is canon
impossible come on des multiplayer of
course returns and introduces more
progression than before there's a much
deeper class system for troopers which
can be upgraded as you play and
customized the same goes for heroes
which include Darth Maul Yoda Luke Rey
and kylo Ren troopers will be themed for
the planet you're on and what era the
battles in but it seems like heroes
won't be it's also not clear how exactly
you'll get heroes during the course of
battle but they're not just power-ups
anymore
there will be some sort of resource
based system and it sounds like the devs
want heroes to be more accessible
vehicles and multiplayer work the same
way troopers and heroes do you can
upgrade and customize them there are
more run-of-the-mill vehicles like TIE
fighters as well as hero ships like the
Millennium Falcon there are also
writable tontons
and space battles that we don't know yet
if that means galactic conquest is back
or not
EA has said that battlefront 2 won't
have a season pass for DLC which
hopefully means that it won't have the
divided community that battlefront had
as far as extra content goes though
there are a few pre-order bonuses that
give you upgrades and early access to
the game plus some last Jedi themed
looks for ray and Kyle Oh finally
battlefront two comes out on November
17th for PC ps4 and Xbox one we'll have
all the details right here as we get
them so stay tuned and let us know in
the comments what you want to see from
battlefront 2 at e3
[Music]